at the bell auto auction room 490 000
tons of fruit and vegetables are sold
every year the sales take place using
six auction clocks which display the
name of the product its quality and the
price for potential buyers the first
buyer to signal his or her intention to
purchase the produce closes the
transaction
this auction this clock is starting at a
certain price this price is the start
price is being based uh on the market
situation
it starts turning counterclockwise until
some of these buyers here push at a
certain price and then they get
connection with the people who are in
front of this room who are the sellers
and then they can decide how much volume
they want to take at this price they
have been pushing
this system also has a positive impact
on reducing food waste
we are able to sell
everything every day completely this
means no production no products will be
left here after this auction is
finished
so tomorrow we start with the fresh
production which is being
supplied here this afternoon by our
growers
if there are any leftover batches of
vegetables they are not sold the next
day instead they are donated to
charities and food banks